this morning we've got Conde Nas
traveler's new list of best places to
visit the magazine announced its annual
Readers Choice Awards this week readers
rated their favorite destinations
cruises and airlines out of all the
large U.S cities Chicago was their top
place to visit
Charleston was number one for small U.S
cities Singapore was first choice for
large cities in the rest of the world
and travelers say the best country to
visit right now is Portugal I hear Tony
has been there Aaron florio's executive
editor of Conde Nash traveler good
morning how are you doing good morning
yeah I'm doing great so Chicago once
again best place to visit in the U.S why
so right so I want to say this is a
really exciting week excuse me for
Connie last traveler it's like you said
we announced our Readers Choice Awards
best destinations hotels Cruise Lines
Chicago best number one number one big
city in the United States this is not
the first time Chicago has won we
definitely sent a pattern here and you
know I think it's almost it's kind of
obvious why Chicago always nabs this
this is about like negative
it's very cold we get it when it's warm
yeah but I think some people see a
positive in the four very defined
Seasons looking at it in a nice way but
like you said summer I mean it's a
landlocked city with a beach right like
it doesn't get it doesn't get better
than that and also you know the top of
the game for food for architecture for
culture yeah
um you know and this year there have
been so many new openings great
restaurants like Esme are really upping
the ante on the food and what we also
love about the food is that you know
it's this amazing mix of high and low
it's deep dish pizza and it's you know a
Linea which will blow your mind of
course and and I think this has to be
said it's accessible from both the east
coast and the West Coast so it can be
you know a long weekend destination
regardless of where you are in the U.S
yeah
so what about Portugal I hear that
Portugal is this hot spot we were
talking during a commercial break you
said you've been there twice Tony I did
Katie and I went with no kids and it was
it was a lovely lovely married weekend
so uh yeah I I have to say I wasn't
surprised at all that Portugal got the
number one country in the world it has
been so hot for so long now everybody
you speak to is either coming back from
Portugal planning a trip to Portugal and
it's been like this for a number of
years not for nothing they handled covid
really really well made people feel you
know good about returning to to to
international travel and you know they
kind of have everything they have the
beaches that you want to go to they've
got really Chic coastal towns like
comporta melides Lisbon is a fantastic
City and then you have the dwaro valley
if you want to do wine if you want to do
river cruising and it's a small country
so it's easy to explore sort of all in
one go the coastline really looks like
Game of Thrones like dragons are going
to come in it's very dramatic yeah it's
very sweeping it is yeah uh but I want
to go back to a place I've spent even
more time and I really love Charleston
South Carolina yeah it's a fantastic
Place such a great City and anyone who's
ever been will not be surprised that
year after year it gets the top U.S
small U.S city I'm surprised Savannah
Georgia though is not a close competitor
yeah I mean no no
Dan is a great City too but there's
something about Charleston
they're always sort of ranked Charleston
kind of always edges it out just a
little bit you know I think it has it
has a little bit of everything it has
this fantastic history and architecture
it's such a small City it's great to
walk around in you can even you know
bike around all of Charleston in a day
and plus I know I said this about
Chicago the food in Charleston is is
just Next Level it's it's you know the
only thing I've ever found stressful
about going to Charleston is like like
really planning all of my meals you know
very strategically it is yeah on
airlines real quickly how about ranking
Airlines because it's been a tough year
for air travels yeah it's been a tough
year they had a tough summer I mean I do
think people passengers still need to
remember that a lot of these Airlines
and a lot of the travel industry is
still recovering from covered you know
service is a little bit slow they're
they're short staffed so a little bit of
patience goes a long way but I think
with Airlines people are voting kind of
for for two reasons one of course you
want to get where you want to where
you're meant to be going on time and you
want your bags to come with you yeah I
think that's why Delta nab's the number
one spot Delta ranks really consistently
high in all of those categories making
sure you leave the terminal on time and
then finally you know people are voting
on Comfort I like to say that my
vacation starts when I walk onto the
plane that's the sign of a good Airline
and I think places like JetBlue
Aaron Florio you're the best appreciate
you thank you